hello everyone and welcome to a most
impressive game from round eight of the
world and not world uh european um a
rapid championship but the blitz
championship finished youngshisto do
that won that event so uh very nicely
done but now we are in the rapids and
this is one of the games that was
suggested to me so do check it out and
also uh i would just like to mention
that um krasenkov even though being uh
58 years old plays like uh well plays
more aggressive than many 20 year olds
and we already covered two games by him
uh in i think the past two months uh so
do check them out as well uh both uh
games will be in the description below
the first thing you will see so you will
enjoy them very much if you still
haven't seen them so uh mikhail of po
poland versus igor kovalenko of latvia
uh let's check it out uh and uh also i
will be announcing uh the pre-christmas
uh leeches arena but that after we check
out the game so let's uh let's check it
out the sync of with the white pieces
opens with knight to f3 he goes for the
reti opening we have c5 uh going for the
the so-called sicilian invitation
because white can just play e4 and then
we're playing the sicilian but he plays
c4 we have knight to c6 and the d4 now
we have c captures knight captures and
now knight to f6 knight to c3 and the g6
so a very very sharp variation both uh
all four knights have been developed and
black is ready to fianchetto his dark
square bishop uh e4 uh krasenkov grabs
the center bishop to g7 and bishop to e3
adding more defense to that d4 square
d6 and bishop to e2 so both players just
nicely developing here both players
castle castle's castles and now the
chapter d7 uh continuing development and
now now usually white will go some like
queen to d2 to maybe prepare bishop to
h6 the trade of the dark square bishops
also this will connect the rooks but
krasenko goes for f4 it's a very very
straightforward uh way to attack uh
black setup and gain more pressure in
the center he's still waiting to see
where the queen will be developed we
have rooked the c8 and now again rook to
c1 makes sense as black already
developed the rook the c8 but white
continues in a most
unprecedented way he plays knight back
to c2 and it is already as of movie 11
that we have a completely new game so he
doesn't want to allow the knights to be
traded on d4
and it's now going to be a very
complicated game which if you like
complicated games uh you know with a
lower time format it can go very well
for you so here we have a6 and bishop to
f3 the bishop will be much stronger here
we have bishop to e6 now attacking the
c4 pawn and white defends it by placing
a knight in between so knight d5 and
knight to d7 now putting pressure on the
b2 pawn so white defends it and now
queen to a5 as a2 pawn is now weak so
we're gonna attack it a white defense it
with a3 and now b5 and here
what do i always say when the
opportunity presents itself uh go for
that uh a b for pawn push and cross and
go of course goes for it we have b4 and
now what uh what do you go uh where do
you go with the queen well this is
covered by the knight you can go to d8
or you can go to a4 uh kovalenko decides
to remain active with the queen he plays
queen to a4 and now okay c5 and e5 are
both tactically sound but it's a rapid
game so you don't have all that much
time to calculate we have queen to d2
and already i believe white was
trying to figure out how to trap the
black queen can the queen be trapped
somehow okay if this knight ever moves
obviously knight to b6 will trap the
queen but also uh if the bishop does not
cover the c3 square knight the c3 will
also trap the queen so black has to be
very careful here
and here we have bishop captures on c3
eliminating uh well one of the pieces
that can trap black's queen e captures
on d5 and now knight c to b8 uh we have
knight to d4 now again uh it's a very
powerful piece and you are kind of
threatening bishop to d1 which could be
very dangerous but okay for the moment
the queen can capture the a3 pawn but
it's not uh as straightforward as it
seems just to give you an example if
let's say bishop captures on d4 okay
it's not just that you're giving up your
strong bishop it's uh uh also
bad for your queen because let's say
bishop d1 attacks the queen queen
captures an a3 and now you capture it
for example
uh this uh bishop on d4
how do you uh prevent rook to f3 and the
queen is trapped there's no way to avoid
this it's just a really really bad
position uh for black to be in so you
have to be very careful so he plays b
captures on c4 uh that makes sense now
the queen will have access to this
diagonal but for the moment these
squares are off limit so you have to
move this knight in order to create an
escape route for for for the queen so
here okay queen bishop to d1 isn't
really as potent now the queen can
capture on a3 and you don't have any uh
further way of uh capturing the black
queen so queen to a2 now defending the
a3 pawn and now you are threatening
bishop to d1 so black has to move the
knight knight of six and now okay the
queen can go back uh rook after c1 and
now we have c3 advancing his pass pawn
now this is a very dangerous pass pawn
but uh well there are so many white
pieces here that it's uh it's unclear as
how you will push it any further rook to
b3 white of course now wants to win back
the pawn and now a5 we have queen to b1
as the pawns will get traded off on the
b file we want to have knight a nice
support for advancing our past b pawn so
a captures on b4a captures and now rook
to c7 with ideas of doubling up here but
also just rook b7 to
stop that past pawn we have rook b
captures on c3 attacking on c7 and rook
b7 now ready to pick up this pawn but
now rook the c for defending uh you
might be wondering why not rook to b3 we
always put a rook behind our pass pawn
but here b5 is coming because the knight
is guarding that b5 square so the queen
will get exposed and then you're going
to be able to put the rook on b4 if
needed so knight beat the d7 uh now
getting this knight into the game also
preparing to bring the other rook into
the game and b5 now uh we have queen to
a3 attacking the bishop and now rook one
to c3 uh defending and attacking the
queen queen back to a8 and now knight
the c6 so you can see uh white uh
achieved a pretty powerful position
without uh sacrificing even a single
pawn okay he tried but then black had to
give it up and uh well and now white
just has a very firm grip on black's
position and attacking the e7 pawn so
here at knight b6 the rook now defends
the pawn also attacks the white rook
here
and bishop captures on v6 giving up this
bishop for a knight is a very
interesting decision but uh well you
will win that e7 pawn so at least that
rook captures knight captures on e7 with
check king to h8 and now knight the c8 a
very tricky move attacking the rook and
the d6 pawn and there's no way for the
rook to defend the pawn so rook back to
b8 and now knight captures on uh d6 and
now white has two past pawns so knight
captures on d5 black decides to
eliminate one of them but
placing the knight you know in front of
the bishop like this with the queen on
a8
isn't as dangerous as it seems because
queen a7 check you will be able to unpin
very quickly so rook d3 attacking the
knight queen to a7 check we have king h1
and now knight to b6 blockading the pawn
with the knight knights are excellent
blockers of past pawns and rook to c6
now
putting pressure on that knight queen to
a4
attacking the f4 pawn and white just
defends with g3 and now king back to g8
uh trying to get the rook into the game
so the king defends the f7 pawn but when
did the king defending uh you know the
f7 pawn
ever really worked out all that well uh
so here we have queen to g1 now putting
pressure on that knight so black has to
react to this queen to a5 defending and
now queen to e3 nicely centralizing the
queen
we have knight to d7 and now as the
knight is preparing to go to f6 we're
gonna shift our bishop bishop to d5
knight f6 and bishop to c4 we are
defending our past pawn and
if you look at the position now okay
black has this monster bishop on g7 but
what is this bishop actually doing in
this game uh can you even imagine
something happening here uh you know on
these squares or even along this
diagonal white has a light square bishop
the b pawn is being pushed so although
yes it's a it's sort of a dragon but not
not really in this game it's not so
queen to a1 check we have king to g2 and
now knight to g4 again in control of
some very important squares here but
again how can black reach them queen e2
not allowing even a single check to be
given also putting pressure on on this
knight here right back to h6 and now
white continues to advance the past pawn
we have b6 uh queen to a4 putting
pressure on the rook and now just bishop
to d5 defending the rook we have rook
after d8 finally the other rook joins
the game
as the knight here is helping out with
the defense of the f7 pawn but now just
b7 and this is now such a such a
dangerous pass pawn uh that it's not
clear how black can even continue the
game black played bishop to f8 if he can
he would very much enjoy giving this
well we have to say it as it is useless
bishop for this monster knight on d6 uh
but the game is now completely winning
for white so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find this uh
incredible idea uh while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
king defending the f7 pawn isn't really
going to work out and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's of
course knight captures on f7 and yes it
looks weird because you are guarding
this square twice but that's just how
chess works and the problem is you can't
capture on f7 with the knight because we
just capture and after king captures
queen e6 check and there's no getting
out of this king g7 rook c7 check and it
doesn't matter what you play for example
king h6 you're gonna get queen to h3
checkmate and all the other lines don't
end well for black so instead we have
rook captures on d5 not allowing any
discoveries to be made but now we have
knight captures on h6 with the check and
again the knight cannot be captured if
you capture the knight queen e6 check
king to h8 and now rook to c8 that's it
you either start giving up everything uh
with some silly moves like queen e8 the
bishop here rook here uh or you capture
here and then we bring another queen
into the game so instead after this
check we have king to g7 a sad move but
it has to be played now rook c7 check we
force the black king to go to h6 king
captures on h6 and now rook captures on
d5 and now look at this white still has
the past b pawn he completely exposed
the black king forced him into discovery
and uh well not only that he's up
material he's up the exchange and it
doesn't matter what black plays here
you're getting checkmated whatever you
play but here queen to b3 was played and
we've reached the position from the
thumbnail so you can see uh
already what what white play look at the
rook nicely controlling the seventh rank
uh look at um the pawn covering the g5
square well uh taking that into
consideration there is only one move and
this is what krasenkov played rook to h5
with check as the queen defends the h5
square the only legal move for black is
to capture the rook with the pawn
because the king can't go anywhere and
now after the rook is captured look at
this we still have to visualize all of
the squares that the rook covers and the
pawn covers g5 so any check along the
sixth rank uh does not end well for
black so this is what uh cresenko played
he played queen to a6 check and he was
in this position on move 52 that igor
kovalenko resigned to the game as there
is nothing more to be done here so it's
just an incredible incredible attacking
game with uh such a powerful finish rook
to h5 check is it's just amazing and
here you're getting checkmated whatever
you do you can start you know giving up
some pieces with some silly moves like
this like this like this and then once
white gobbles up everything that's it
you are you are checkmated
so yeah another incredible game by
mikhail krasenko uh like i said do check
out the two of his other games in the
description below because
you know whenever we cover a game he
played it's just uh you know just an
attacking masterpiece which i i really
am impressed because at his age playing
such such powerful uh creative chess
it's uh definitely not easy to achieve
so i imagine he's um well uh
i either live living a very healthy
lifestyle or maybe like tal uh not
living a healthy life lifestyle at all
but whatever he's doing it is going
great for him
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh like i said uh in the
description uh after the two games by
cressingho will be a link to the lyches
arena it will be a pre-christmas uh
lyches arena uh with some very nice
prizes so do join us we're to be
streaming um uh it's going to be on the
21st of december uh starting uh 8 p.m
central european time
and it will last for some two hours uh
the best players win of course will be
awarded some very nice pri prizes the
prizes will be uh distributed and uh
sponsored by cakedefy.com uh so uh you
know do check it out and you know join
us i i'm expecting a lot of players to
join so you know not all of you might
win but you will get many chances to
face uh some very very strong players in
the arena so yeah uh once again hope you
guys enjoyed that i would like to thank
francis here we were sky music emmanuel
freitzel now duncan uh weincall and
william fuller for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of these nights
nice events uh and checking up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and i
forgot to mention krasenkov is now uh
co-leading the tournament after nine
rounds of the rapid so uh we will see
how it goes uh see you soon